Dr Zak here which is the second most
serious and sinful act which invalidates
the fast during Ramadan the second most
serious thing that breaks the fast or
invalidates the fast it is
masturbation and this we get from the
Hadith of our beloved Prophet M wasallam
let mentioned
in sayari volume number three in the
book of fasting Hadith number 1894
where the Prophet said that Allah
said that all the Deeds of the son of
Adam are for himself except for fasting
it's for me and I will reward him and
further he says that the person he
leaves he abstains from eating and
drinking and his desires for my sake
Allah says the person abstains from
eating drinking and his desires for my
sa now this desire from here we come to
know it includes even masturbation so
when a person masturbates or ejaculates
whether by touching his wife or looking
at his wife or or for other reason or
looking at any other woman and if
ejaculation takes place then the fast
gets invalidated he has to repent to
Allah subhana tala and complete that day
of fasting and he should compensate for
this fast keep this fast lat later after
the Raman gets over but here there's no
kafara there's no penalty well that
penalty is only for a sexual intercourse
here because intercourse hasn't taken
place there is no penalty you should
only repent make up that fast that fast
you should complete and then make up for
that fast later on but if a person does
not ejaculate and if there is Mii which
comes out fluid then the F does not
break similarly this is the prostatic
fluid the Mii
and if the V comes out that is after
unation a white fluid then two the F
does not break only thing he has to do
isan he should watch the private parts
and do woo the fast does not break he
can complete the fast and continue the
fast